لازم نعرف ان في امريكا في قوانين تحد من
وصول معلومات وبيانات المستخدمين
الموجودين داخل امريكا خارج امريكا وهي
بيانات يعني قوانين معترف فيها اذا كان في
اكثر من مليون شخص مستخدم لمنصه معينه او
مليون امريكي مستخدمه هذه المنصه يجب ان
تكون بيانات من الصوص سيرفراتها تحت اداره
امريكيه او تكون داء موجوده داخل امريكا
ولا يكون لها الطلاع من اي مكان حول
العالم طبعا الموضوع هذا مو جديد من ايام
الرئيس الامريكي الاسبق كان يتكلم ان تكتب
ترى يعتبر في مشاكل ويجب ان يطبق القوانين
الامريكيه الجديده عشان الناس الصين
موجوده وترى المعلوم الصين عندها نفس
القوانين لا يوجد اي منصه اجتماعيه تعمل
في الصين الا بقوانين الصين فلذلك كل
الدول لها قوانين معينه همم تحكم الدخول
يعني مثلا تويتر الصين لا يطبق القوانين
الصينيه فيسبوك ما موجود في الصين لكن
موجود لا بدائل كان متواجد في الصين في
فتره لكن طلع حاليا
ده في الصين بسبب القوانين الموجوده في
الصين